much of the reason why we give up far
too soon fall into Despair and abandon
our projects is not just because they're
hard per se but because they are harder
far harder than we'd ever expected them
to be it isn't necessarily difficulty
that SNS us it's bad ideas about what a
noble task should legitimately demand of
us we operate with Dangerously In
adequate views of what it takes for
anything good to happen of what it might
take for example to have a moderately
good relationship to run a more or less
viable business to have a circle of
friends to be healthy to build a home or
to achieve a balanced mind so we lose
our tempers cry and scream because we
perceive injustices where there are in
fact only encounters with entirely
reasonable and predictable degrees of
pain a wise Society than our own would
include in every school curriculum a
weekly class titled hell your future
which would systematically induct young
people into the necessary degrees of
suffering required by any worthwhile
life we would realize that we make
people strong not by enchanting them
with descriptions of a life full of
opportunities but by being honest about
how things tend actually to go it isn't
cute to educate young people for a world
world that doesn't exist thric married
couples would address the Young on the
complexities of Love cancer survivors
would deliver lessons on the
preciousness of time artists and
entrepreneurs would testify to the huge
yet vital sacrifices required to produce
results that look easy no young person
should be left under the slightest
illusion that fulfilling moments demand
anything other than torment and they
would as a result be in a far better
place to attain good things one day wise
people keep going not because they're
braver but because they've learned to be
a lot better prepared they know that
defeats and humiliation are unavoidable
events not freakish punishments they
Wonder at the close of every quiet day
why not more has gone wrong they succeed
on the basis of fully expecting
everything to be just about as hard as
it probably really will
be